foreign
don't be scared
we've met before
are you looking for Reagan are you
looking for Reagan
Trainor
what do you think evil is
oh
I'll tell you what I think it is
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams
and a desire to be happy
that's going on with my daughter
it's happening to my daughter too
the devil has one wish Wherever those
girls went they brought something back
with him
to make us lose faith I believe if you
can help get our daughters back to kill
it in this and the devil never gives up
she knows who I am
where's the other girl
[Music]
what you're doing here is dangerous
people have died on both sides of
possession
come on baby
okay
if you don't make it I don't make it
mama what is it baby
I'm right here I don't want to go to
hell
what's wrong
what did you do
a girl lives one girl dies
thank you